et avec nous maintenant caroline
senneville présidente de la csn bonsoir
bonsoir est-ce que vous comme uni fort
la csn se prononce officiellement en vue
du vote 20 septembre nos statuts
règlements sont très calmes très clair à
cet effet la csn n'a depuis jamais aucun
parti politique alors ce qu'on fait
c'est qu'on dit aux partis politiques on
profite du débat électoral du débat
démocratique pour mettre de l'avant les
revendications qu'on a pour les
travailleurs les travailleuses
alors c'était la journée justement pour
mettre en valeur ses revendications
journée de la fête du travail l'une des
revendications c'est justement de
demander au gouvernement legault de
revoir son projet de loi 59 sur la
réforme de la santé sécurité au travail
ça fait presque un an qu'on a déposé ce
projet de loi vous êtes contre la
réforme en tout cas ce qui est proposé
en ce moment pourquoi
en fait on est on est content qu'il ya
une révision de la loi sur la santé cds
loi il y en a deux importants parce que
ça fait 40 ans qu'on doit pas toucher
ces mais c'est costaud comme
modifications plus d'une centaine
d'amendements il faut aller en
prévention en réparation la gouvernance
aussi
puis je voudrais que on est content de
certaines avancées du côté de la
prévention qui reste le dernier bout a
adopté parce que on va étendre les
mécanismes de prévention de plus large
part des secteurs économiques alors
avant c'était juste une partie congrue
mais il faut se donner les moyens de
pouvoir faire de la prévention donc ça
prend des personnes qui sont dédiés pour
faire de la prévention dans les milieux
de travail qui sont libérés pour faire
cette prévention là et c'est là dessus
qu'on a encore du chemin à faire parce
que vous souhaitez que la prévention
soit davantage associés à la partie
syndicale ou du moins le choix des
personnes qui font de la prévention que
ça vienne également du côté des
travailleurs pour ce soit véritablement
paritaire bien sûr que les travailleurs
aient leur mot à dire pour que cette
personne n'en soit efficace il faut
qu'elle ait la confiance des
travailleurs et des travailleuses ont
fait puis yeux rien comme quelqu'un qui
fait le travail pour connaître les
dangers inhérents et pouvoir les
partager avec ses collègues et faire des
outils de prévention qui peuvent exister
aussi d'avoir des comités santé-sécurité
paritaire sur ma terre ok parfait vous
ramenez eux aussi à l'avant plan le fait
qu' il ya des lois spéciales qui peuvent
exister pour le retour au travail
récemment quand même on n'a pas vu le
gouvernement imposer de retour forcé au
travail or on a vu dans la construction
la fonction publique même dans les
conflits privé comme un email exceldor
ya pas eu de loi spéciale du
gouvernement
absolument puis je voudrais que c'est
pas un hasard nécessairement parce que
la jurisprudence a quand même changé au
canada sa vie que le droit de s'associer
de former syndicats et en sachet dans
les chats québécoise et canadienne puis
la cour suprême au par la jurisprudence
aussi
donner notre le droit d' abbey on sait
où on est on est associés où on est on
est anciens du cos pourquoi pour
négocier donc on a le droit de négocier
et on a le droit aussi de faire valoir
un rapport de force pour négocier et
sans la jurisprudence a évolué donc je
sens les gouvernements plus plus prudent
de ce côté là
dans la campagne en ce moment fédéral il
est beaucoup question de la réforme de
l'assurance emploi vous attendez quoi en
quelques mots le tue
c'est fondamental sur 100 personnes qui
cotisent à l'assurance emploi au moment
où on se parle 39 ont droit à des
prestations d'assurance emploi c'est
inqualifiable je vous dirai ça pas de
sens le régime ne fonctionne plus ça a
été dit il faut absolument faire en
sorte qu'ils aient plus de trous noirs
c'est une période où on n'a plus du tout
de prestations d'assurance emploi quand
on est dans l'est du sri saisonnière il
ya des raids des régions du québec du
canada qui dépendent des bus tice
saisonnière il faut faire en sorte aussi
des cantons travail à temps partiel ce
qui touche beaucoup les femmes ben qu'on
soit nu couvert les travailleurs
autonomes que je voudrais ce qui est
arrivé avec la pandémie c'est la mer
preuve que le régime d'assurance-emploi
vraiment besoin d'être formé les
libéraux promettent 15 $ l'heure pour
les employés fédéraux salaire minimum et
une pda évoqué 20 $ l'heure aujourd'hui
pour les employés fédéraux la ftq
réclame un salaire minimum général de 18
$ et vous à la csn mais on va se reposer
la question on était sur l'a15 leurs
dollars sur ce qui est art visée parce
que
c'est ça c'est pas sa fin ce qui au delà
des chiffres ce qui est important c'est
que quelqu'un qui travaille autour de 40
heures par semaine au salaire minimum
devrait être ne devrait pas avoir peur
du lendemain économiquement parlant et
devraient pas avoir peur que sa voiture
brice qu'il est une carie est qu'ils
soient plus obligés de s'endetter par
exemple alors il faut absolument que
vous savez on en a parlé la crise du
logement le coût du logement augmenter
le coût des aliments augmenter avec la
pandémie les inégalités sociales ont
augmenté alors je pense qu'il faut
vraiment se questionner sur un système
économique qui fait en sorte que même à
travaillant tous qu'il faut qu'en mer on
n'est pas capable de se sortir de la
pauvreté donc au delà de 15 18 ou 20 il
faut absolument que le salaire
permettent aux gens de vivre dignement
est ce que vous considérez puis on fait
toujours cette réflexion là qu'il faut
le faire de temps de temps en temps
certainement que les conditions de
travail se détériorent de façon générale
se détériore s'effrite
si sur ce à quoi nous quand on syndic
des gens je peux vous dire que des fois
on était moins de conditions travail
assez ahurissante oui
c'est je voudrais le contrôle sur le
travail avec toutes les technologies on
parle du droit à la déconnexion mais moi
j'appelle pas son droit à la déconnexion
j'appelle sont simplement le droit au
repos est-ce qu'on peut être un moment
donné chez soi et price en attente d'un
coup de fil ou à la merci d'un courriel
pour se remettre au travail sans aucun
préavis donc il faut vraiment léon le vu
aussi la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre des
effets pervers parce que quand tu
manques de leader mais sa surcharge les
gens qui sont qui sont déjà en poste que
ce soit dans le secteur privé ou dans le
secteur public qui on l'a vu notamment
en santé mais c'est vrai ailleurs aussi
donc je pense que là il faut saisir
l'occasion de la rareté de main-d'oeuvre
pour justement qu'on voit que le
personnel les ressources humaines c'est
quelque chose de très précieux et de les
traiter correctement parfait madame
cnvdt merci merci d'avoir été avec nous
ça me fait plaisir à voir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne i see her dit